gerne lässt nicht wenn man weiß wie man
am besten lernt
aber reicht es nicht dass wir ständig
lernen müssen jetzt müssen wir auch noch
das lernen lernen naja man kann mit
sicherheit sagen die moderne unsere welt
wird desto mehr ansprüche stellt sie an
uns wir müssen unser leben lang lernen
nicht nur in der schule deswegen
beschäftigen sich wissenschaftler schon
seit über 100 jahren mit lehrern
forschung um herauszufinden welche
methoden am effektivsten sind heute gebe
ich euch dazu einen kleinen überblick
nämlich die vier häufigsten fehler die
wir beim leeren machen und wie man sie
vermeiden kann lernt wieder normales zu
viel auf einmal er kennt das nicht die
klausur ist in zwei tagen deswegen ist
die nächsten zwei nächte nichts mit
schlaf wie soll ich den sonnenkraft
alles hier in meinem gehirn bekommt gut
ist grundlegend rum lebens hier
natürlich das programmieren als das
aufschieben vom lernen dazu gibt es auch
diese zwei videos von uns aber
vielleicht motiviert durch erfolgen des
um das aufschieben nichts übertreiben
nämlich portionsweise lernen ist
nachgewiesenermaßen viel effektiver als
viel auf einmal zu lernen denn jetzt
besuchte montags 50 neue vokabeln rhein
zu pfeifen
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr
die bis zum wochenende wieder vergessen
habt ziemlich groß besser ist es jeden
tag also montag bis freitag jeweils nur
zehn vokabeln zu lernen unser gehirn
funktioniert nämlich nicht wie die
festplatte eines computers die einfach
mit daten voll geschrieben wird sondern
es ist ein sich ständig wandelndes
netzwerks immer wieder neue
verknüpfungen entstehen und ich kleinere
lehrern anhalten und regelmäßigen pausen
können wir die bildung dieser neuen
verknüpfungen besser unterstützen
kleinere lerneinheiten bedeutet aber
nicht dass unser gehirn eine bestimmte
lehrern kapazität hat ganz im gegenteil
die fähigkeit neue verbindungen zu
knüpfen ist potenziell unerschöpflich
und menschen die bereits viel gelernt
haben fällt es in der regel leichter
neue inhalte zu behalten lernen fehler
nummer zwei das passive abhaken von fakt
ich nenne das umgangssprachlich für
schultes lernen ohne den schulen damit
zu nahe treten zu wollen was ich damit
meine ist einfach das sture
auswendiglernen von fakten ohne größeren
kontext wir lernen grammatikregeln und
vokabeln auswendig
wir lernen jahreszahlen in geschichte
namens reaktion in der chemie durch das
alleine ist eigentlich zeit verschwenden
und stattdessen lernen wir am besten
durch verknüpfen wenn wir uns klar
machen dass unser gehirn ein blitz der
parole dass sich immer wieder neu
verknüpft dann verstehen wir auch dass
wir lernen in denen wir neues mit altem
und bekannten verknüpfen anstatt eine
vokabel nur hat der übersetzung zu
lernen merke ich sie mir viel besser
wenn ich versuche mit dieser vokabel
möglichst viele verschiedene
zusammenhängende sätze zu bilden und am
besten ist es wenn ich mir sätze aus
denke die ich so auch im alltag
gebrauchen könnte und eine chemische
reaktion mehr hatte ich mir viel besser
wenn ich zb weiß wofür diese reaktion
gut ist und inwiefern sie sich von
anderen reaktionen die ich schon kenne
unterscheidet oder wo es vielleicht
ähnlichkeiten gibt jetzt verstehen wir
auch warum menschen die bereits viel
gelernt haben leichter noch mehr neues
wäre schlichtweg mehr anknüpfungspunkte
mit denen die neue information vernetzt
werden kann und die wichtigste frage
fürs lernen ist nicht wer wie was oder
wann sondern warum wenn wir uns ständig
fragen warum etwas so ist wie es ist
entstehen dadurch viel mehr
verknüpfungen und so lernen wir viel
effektiver und das sogar wenn wir keine
antwort auf die warum frage bekommen
lernt fehler nummer drei immer dieselben
lernmethoden leben er hat doch bestimmt
auch schon mal gehört dass jeder mensch
ein bestimmter lerntyp ist oder ich bin
ein visueller lerner ich lerne am besten
wenn ich das höre doch diese hypothese
nämlich dass bestimmte lernmethoden für
bestimmte personen besonders geeignet
sind ist bei experten weitestgehend
überholt höchstens handelt es sich hier
um 10 15 profis das heißt wenn ich
glaube dass sich visuell besonders gut
lernen kann dann fördert allein mein
glaube der rand bereits gelernt
effizienz in wirklichkeit ist es am
effektivsten so variabel wie möglich zu
lernen also durchlesen notieren sich
laut vorlesen sich abfragen lassen tests
machen und praktische übungen
je breiter der methodenmix desto größer
die lerner von übrigens die beliebteste
lehrmethode unter schülern und studenten
halten experten für eine der
ineffizientesten weise so passiert
nehme ich das anstreichen von text mit
hicks marke fertig und zuletzt leer
entweder nummer vier angst vor fehlern
haben klassisches beispiel sprachen
lernen wenn wir gerade eine neue sprache
lernen oder schlichtweg einfach nur
nicht so gut darin sind vermeiden wir
jede gelegenheit unsere sprachkenntnisse
im echten leben zu testen gott wie
peinlich und würde sich in opladen und
genau das ist der fehler denn
selbstständiges reproduzieren von
gelerntem also dass sie ständig testen
oder testen lassen ist essentiell nicht
um neues besser zu lernen sondern auch
um es länger im gedächtnis zu behalten
genauso wichtig ist es zu wissen was man
nicht weiß oder nicht kann
das hängt mit dem zusammen was ich
vorhin über den kontext gesagt haben
lasst euch doch mal vor der nächsten
geschichts klausur oder für sie klausur
vor dem freund so richtig wie es bis ins
kleinste detail aus fragen wenn ihr
kennt was ihr noch nicht wisst oder was
ihr noch nicht verstanden habt dann
hilft es euch nicht nur dabei das
versäumte nachzuholen sondern als hilft
euch sogar dabei das was ihr bereits
bist besser zu verinnerlichen jedoch
lerntipps habt dann teilt sie bitte in
den kommentaren ansonsten wünschen euch
viel spaß beim lernen schlauer über eure
lerntipps freue ich mich natürlich
genauso sehr wie über eure fragen dh
wenn ihr fragen habt ihr gerne mal in
einem video beantwortet haben möchte
schreibt sie in den kommentaren hier
sehen uns nächste woche bis sein bleibt
sicher